for killing Winston Jones you said that
the financing fell through three times
what were some of the obstacles you were
up against obstacles that that writers
and producers and everyone is up against
on every project I was in a unique
situation with killing Winston Jones
because I developed a relationship with
the director and so I was a part of the
entire process I was a part of
pre-production as a part of production
I'm a part of post-production now so I
was in a unique situation where I was
wearing a lot of different hats so when
Joel and I were developing it we were
constantly working together so that
meant we were going out to producers we
were going out to investors we were
going out to casting agents we were
going out to anyone they would read it
they could help us put together a
package so the the challenges that
happen were that we were attaching
people that were good that were you know
friends of Joel's or just people who
liked the script and we were getting
investors that were interested and
investors that really wanted to make the
film and we're willing to option it and
put in the time but because of different
reasons they weren't able to finance it
at the end so you know sometimes
production companies will have a slate
of three films that year and one will go
way over budget and another one will get
pushed and you know there's just there's
always different reasons why financing
can fall through so unfortunately for us
that happened on three different
occasions I mean for some films it
happens 10 x 20 x 30 times you know for
other films they get financing they move
forward you know we the third time when
we lost financing within 48 hours the
producer that we had attached Taylor
heart is his name who is an incredible
producer very hungry and driven and
getting a lot of projects done now
within 48 hours of the last time that we
had our financing fall through he found
another production company and they
brought all the money to the table so
with that we were able to start
pre-production the next day so we you
know we had a terrible weekend thinking
the film was once again shut down and on
Monday we were flying out to
van in Georgia to shoot the film so it
just every single time you try to get a
film in production or even in a
pre-production and get the financing
you're going to find obstacles along the
way so the financing falling through was
just the very first obstacle even you
know the first day of production
actually we were working in Savannah
Georgia as I had mentioned it's a right
to work state we weren't unionized
across the board so of course we had sag
we were atl unionized so everything
above the line was unionized we were sag
with some of our other departments
weren't completely unionized so I don't
know exactly which ones they were I feel
like it might have been makeup or hair
or or costume design but on the very
first day of production the unions and
the Teamsters showed up on set and we're
picketing and they told our crew that
they would have they would be fined five
thousand dollars for working on the film
that they would have their cards revoked
they wouldn't work in this town again
and although that's not true because
Georgia is a right George states so
technically you can shoot a film that's
not entirely unionized but they did
enough damage where half of our crew was
scared and they left and so we lost an
entire day and our production company
had to decide if they were going to pay
to unionize which is a you know
six-figure decision and if they were
going to push production forward and for
several hours we thought that we're
going to be shutting down completely but
luckily we had a strong production
company behind us that that paid that
difference and the wages for everyone
who is working for us became unionized
and increased and we made the film you
know so that was just another challenge
and throughout the process of production
there's challenges every single day you
know and even into post-production it's
it's a lot of creative people working
together and at the end of the day it's
a business so you have different
mentalities you have people who want to
create the best creative process
and product and film and then you have
people that want to make as much money
as they possibly can so even in
post-production we have people seeing
differently you know on the same project
and we just have to find the middle
ground so that we can get it released
and and it will be the challenges that
we have finding distribution you know
getting into the film festivals that we
want to get into and getting into the
amount of theaters and hopefully doing
well with the film so every single
corner is every single corner and every
day as a challenge and getting a film
done
you